merci beaucoup
president
european president
ladies and gentlemen dear colleagues
two days ago i was at the u.n security
council to express
our common european commitment to
condemn russian atrocities and to
reaffirm our support for ukraine
the russian ambassador didn't like what
i said
he worked out
because he refused to look truth in the
eye
but we won't stop telling the truth we
won't stop acting
to back ukraine and to confront russia
with the facts
dear colleagues
russia
is using food as a weapon of war
stealing the grain blockading ports and
turning
farmlands into battlefields
there are over 20 million tons of grain
wheat and corn stuck in ukraine
this is disrupting double food security
driving up prices
and causing global famine during our
european council meeting we focused on
the logistical solutions to get these
products to global markets
including working with ukraine and eu
member states to establish alternative
transport routes
double hungers is everyone's business
so it requires
a coordinated comprehensive and global
approach and we work with the g7 with
the african union and with all the other
partners
in new york a few days ago i met with
secretary general guterres to discuss
global food security and
our common efforts to get the blocked
grain out of odessa
the kremlin
is recognizing food supplies
and surrounding their actions
with
a weapon of lies
soviet style
we must join forces to call all these
fabrications as pure fiction
particularly for the global south
these are
russian ships and russian mission
missiles that are blocking the exports
of crops and grain russian tents bumps
and mines are preventing ukraine from
planting and harvesting
let's be clear these are no use
sanctions on russian agricultural
products and i say to all countries
affected by this food crisis
don't be fooled by the kremlin's
propaganda don't be instrumentalized by
russia
ladies and gentlemen we also reached
a landmark agreement on russian oil
this embargo will cover 90 percent of
all imports from russia into the eu by
the end of the year
this is a remarkable achievement and it
will be extended to all pipeline all as
soon as possible
two months ago in this house i said that
measures on hydrocarbons will be needed
sooner or later and we did it this shows
that we are and we remain united and
committed to piling the pressure on
russia
ladies and gentlemen
ukraine
urgently needs liquidity
5 billion euros a month just to keep the
country running
so we discussed how we can work with our
international partners to get the
ukrainian government the money it needs
we will do it to provide up to nine
billion euros to ukraine in macro
financial assistance and we also address
ukraine's reconstruction right now and
in the future
the eu must be and will be a leader in
driving this forward
we discussed a ukraine reconstruction
platform together with the ukraine
government the eu and member states and
all our international partners and
friends
ladies and gentlemen
russia is brutally destroying ukraine
and it's only fair
that russia the aggressor
should pay to rebuild a country so we
agreed to look into the possibility of
transiting assets of sanctions russian
individuals and entities in line with eu
and international law this could help
science ukraine's reconstruction
russia's war
has bolstered ambition
for a strong coordinated european
defense
in march in versailles we agree to
strengthen our security and to increase
our sovereignty
we want to have defense capabilities
that match today's threats
and we agree to urgently replenish
member states stats of equipment sent to
ukraine and
in the medium and long term do we
enforce our european defense technology
and industrial sector including smes
this means
better coordinating our purchases and
pool in spending for joint procurement
member states lack of cooperation on
defense is costing tens of billions of
euros per year
only 11 percent of member states defense
investments are spent collaboratively
and we are missing huge opportunities
for real savings for economies of steel
and for ensuring that our armed forces
are more interoperable
a more capable eu will strengthen nato
and increase global security
we also discussed energy prices
including the possibility of trying to
lower the gas price by keeping it
together with our international partners
different views remain on the
feasibility and you have therefore
tasked the commission to analyze this
and you are also working to phase out
russian fossil fuel imports and
to become more energy independent
will act in four key areas first we will
diversify the fields we use and the
sources they come from
second we will speed up the deployment
of renewables and the permitting
procedures
third we will do more to save energy and
promote energy efficiency and finally
we'll invest in infrastructure
interconnections and renewables
but our discussions show that much work
remains on the finance aspects of the
commission's proposals and the council
will now take words forward in these
different areas
listen gentlemen dear colleagues
if we want to be a geopolitical power
we must act as a geopolitical power
this means
taking care of ourselves but also taking
care of others
by bending together we can use that
power to become more sovereign and more
prosperous more influential
we are united and committed to back
ukraine and to build our common future i
thank you
thank you
very much president michelle and now i
give the floor to the president of the
european commission ursula on the line
madame president roberta mr president
xiao
ladies and gentlemen honorable members
in the early weeks of this war
you remember that the leaders were
gathering in versailles and europe found
a common sense of purpose
the european commission took
responsibility to translating this
purpose into action
and the european council last week there
we presented our very practical
approaches and proposals on four main
topics
the first one is we have to get rid of
the dependency on russian fossil fuels
we have gotten rid already of coal
we are now
in a phase where we can wind down the
dependency on russian oil 90 till the
end of the year i would have hoped for
100 but this is unanimity so
90
is good till the end of the year and now
we have to look at gas and for that we
presented the 300 billion package
repower eu
what is in it
three main pillars
the first one is diversify away from
russia
towards more trustworthy and
good suppliers friends of us
for example the united states
and to invest in the necessary
infrastructure in a way when i'm
speaking for example about pipelines and
interconnectors that yes today it's for
gas but tomorrow it has to be hydrogen
ready so the investment is worth it
the second part is energy saving
and energy efficiency
sounds so easy is big topic
because i just want to share with you
one figure that really impressed me
if in the european union
over a year we decrease the average
heating temperature by two degrees only
this is the equivalent of the whole
supply of north stream one
two degrees only
and this shows the power of energy
savings and energy efficiency
and the third pillar is the most
important that is massive investment in
renewables and i could speak here for an
hour about that topic but i will not do
that because i have to focus now on the
three other topics the second one is and
was defense at the council
the commission did a gaps analysis
there is a
clear under investment since the
economic and financial crisis you can
see it i give you a few figures that
show that
in the last decade we had an increase in
defense spending in the european union
by 19
the united states 65
russia 300
and china 600
and i think these figures are telling
so now the good news is that
leaders have stepped up and if you look
at the figures they have now put
publicly as investment in defense it's
200 billion now it is important not only
that we have these 200 billion but how
we spend it
and here joint procurement is paramount
because this is a question of ending the
fragmentation of economy of scale of
interoperability and of development of
our industrial base here in the european
union so we really have to look at that
intensively
the third topic was very important on
relief and reconstruction on ukraine
i explained it extensively last time
when we were here in strasbourg so today
i want to focus on food security and
perhaps in my closing remarks it might
be possible to refer to the relief and
reconstruction food security
honorable members the russian invasion
of ukraine we verb reverberates around
the world
this is not just about what its impact
is on economics geopolitics and security
architecture
it is about the lives and livelihoods of
millions of people around the world
millions of people
who fear that they will not be able to
afford tomorrow how to heat their homes
and how to feed their children and the
numbers are stark
this year alone
some
275 million people are likely to be at
least
at the risk of food insecurity across
the world
not to know where to get your food as of
tomorrow
and in an
inflationary world we are in right now
that risk and those numbers can quickly
spiral further out of control
many families in parts of sub-saharan
africa already spent close to half of
their income on food they have no room
to maneuver anymore with rising food
prices no way
so it is no surprise that the world bank
has estimated
that 10 million people are pushed into
extreme poverty
for every percentage point increase in
food prices
10 million people 1
increase
so we should be under no illusions
about the challenges ahead
we are facing up to a collision of
crises
which will amplify food insecurity and
debt distress around the world
some of these are a legacy of the
pandemic
and why the issues linked to the cost of
living for instance the rising energy
prices that have driven up the cost of
fertilizers
or of transporting exports
others are more long-term and structural
such as the effects of extreme weather
linked to climate change
but honorable members
whether cyclical
or structural
of these impacts have one thing in
common
they are massively
and deliberately
compounded by proteins were
and this is a cold callous and
calculated siege by putin on some of the
most vulnerable countries and people in
the world and therefore honorable
members food has become now part of the
kremlin's arsenal of terror and we
cannot tolerate this
i think this is the only way to describe
russia's bombarding of grain storage
the blockage of the ukrainian ports
actually also some cases in some cases
even theft of grain from ukraine
so at the moment being there around
about 20 million tons of grain currently
trapped in ukraine
and it is our duty
to dismantle russia's disinformation
let's be very clear
here in the semi cycle and outside
our sanctions do not touch basic food
commodities
they do not affect the trading of grain
or other food between russia and third
countries
and the port embargo specifically has
full exemption
on agricultural goods
so let's stick to the truth
it's putin's war of aggression that
fuels the feud food crisis and nothing
else
honorable members
while the cause is without doubt
our response
must be just as clear
and there are four areas of action which
i believe we must now focus on together
the first is keeping the markets open
so that trade can continue to flow
this means stepping up our work on the
solidarity lanes
we are working very hard to provide an
alternative way i know it's not optimal
but it's at least something to make sure
that the grain that is blocked in
ukraine gets to the markets as quickly
as possible this helps
but the world needs the black sea ports
of ukraine up and running again
because the majority of ukrainian grain
can only be exported in time through the
black sea routes and therefore i'm very
grateful to the united nations for its
efforts
in parallel
we need to work with our partners to
ensure that there are no exports
export restrictions or controls that
will hamper the market
the european union keeps its foods
export going and so should everyone else
second area this is solidarity and
support to partners
this is about short-term support to the
countries mostly as at risk
for example we are now investing an
additional 225 million euros to address
the short and medium-term needs of the
southern neighborhood partners
and i will be in egypt next week to
discuss with president al-sisi how best
we can target our support to the region
this is a big big task for all of us
the third area is responding and
investing in making local our response
in investing in making local markets
more sustainable and resilient
if you look at the figures
50 years ago
africa produced all the food it needed
only 50 years ago
then climate change
made water scarce
and the desert swallowed hundreds of
kilometers of fertile land year after
year
today africa is heavily dependent on
imports for critical food products
and this makes it vulnerable
and therefore in the medium and long
term an initiative to boost the region's
own production capacity
is critical
to strengthen the region's resilience we
should have the same
set mindset like we did with the
vaccines
yes at the moment being we have to bring
food to africa yes it is the short-term
solution and it is necessary without any
question and we should look at our how
we use our grain here in europe and how
much we can really bring to africa but
in the mid and long term like with the
vaccines it should be the technology
that is in africa and africa produces
itself what it needs
so here we really have to step up
and for this the eu budget has already
earmarked 3 billion euros to invest in
agriculture and nutrition water and
sanitation programs
precision farming nanotechnology for
fertilizers you don't need the energy
anymore so there are many many
interesting technologies out there
but it is clear that we need to do more
and we will need to move faster
and this is why the commission has
raised with member states now
the possibility to mobilize 600 million
euros of decommitted funds
from the european development fund
and please i would be very very happy if
we move swiftly i know that this
parliament is able to do it you have
proven it in the crisis so let's prove
it another time
finally
let me emphasize that we are not doing
this alone we are working very closely
with member states through the team
europe approach
we are working closely with the united
nations and the g7 presidency
that has made this a key theme of the
upcoming leaders meeting
unity and support
are the strongest messages we can send
in the face of russian aggression and
russian disinformation
and honorable members it is only natural
that many of our partners around the
world
see this conflict through the prism
of food and energy crisis
and they expect the european union of
course other countries in the world too
but they expect the european union to
show the same result
the same solidarity as we have rightly
so shown to ukraine
when it comes to addressing the food
crisis
in the world and this is exactly what we
will have to do through our own response
through our work with the g7 and with
other partners long live europe thank
you
thank you
very much
commission president i'll now invite
on behalf of the epp group mumford weber
to take the floor
president mitzola from the line michelle
dear colleagues
yeah let's assess the last council
meeting first of all about sanctions
defense all the other initiatives i
think the outcome is good we made a step
forward europe is on a good way
but i ask myself frankly speaking when
we reflect about the last council
meeting why nobody mentioned
until now the name of viktor oban
because when people
see what and saw what happened in the
last european council i think
they understood that there is
victor oban one of the
crazy guys on the table and this is a
problem for us as europeans
i asked myself how was it to sit next to
him to have the experience to be
blackmailed by victor oban to have
putin's interests sitting on the table
i have a long history personally with
victor robin we kicked him out two years
ago today my party the epp is in
poland in
czech republic for example we kicked out
the corrupt rubbish out of office so we
are the rule of law party today in a lot
of center and eastern european countries
i am proud about this
but again how was it
and i asked these questions you know
because
i think a lot of people all of europe
understand that the current architecture
the current decision-making process is
not anymore giving us answer to the task
of the table
that's why the question again why are
not we are initiating the pasadena
clause in their lisbon 3 divide we don't
discuss these issues and you know the
european parliament will vote tomorrow
on the idea to ask for a convention i
think all colleagues from the other
groups that we find a good text now that
we find a common understanding about our
requests on the table a joint text i
hope that the leaders have enough will
show enough leadership to really
develop the idea of a convention
when we speak about leadership then also
ukraine is
in our mind
the next european council will have to
discuss about the candidate status i
want to remind ourselves that a few days
after
uh the war started
on 24th of february president zielenski
was here on the screen and he was asking
us are we welcomed can we become member
of the club
is it worth to fight that was his
question and i said here like a lot of
my colleagues yes your yes you can join
the european union and that's why it's
so important that we give in the next
european council the clear mandate a
clear signal to the ukraine france that
their fight is a good fight and they are
welcomed in the european family so
that's why we need the decision of a
candidate status now that is what we
need and also for moldova i want to be
clear on this that the republic of
moldova uh respect
has to have the same treatment
i want to i want to underline that this
is part of a broader development for
sure when we speak about western balkan
the whole whole enlargement process is
not only more about the single market it
is today about stability and that's why
we should do it now we should show
leadership again in this aspect and
my group is hardly fighting for this
and then i want to welcome the
initiatives from the commission on the
food security
madam president
a lot of these issues are good issues
and to prioritize this is great
probably generally speaking we can say
farmers are not any more seen as the bad
guys polluting our environment because
that was the perception over the last
years
farmers are those who are working hard
families who are working hard to deliver
high quality food for all of us and that
should be that should be respected that
should be seen especially in the week
where we celebrate 60 years of the cip
and when we speak about the economic
situation dear colleagues for farmers
then i want to ask president um
of the council to consider to put
another item on the agenda of the next
european council because for the moment
we speak a lot about the external
dimension but we don't speak so much
about the concerns of our citizens and
that is about inflation that is about
the interest rates going up in the next
few months uh what we hear from the ecb
the growth rate is not promising for
today's european expectations we are in
front of a recession of a possible
recession
people are confronted with the question
can i
can i uh pay my bill for holidays now or
for a better education for my for my
children that is the question for
citizens in the european union and
that's why politically populists are
already waiting for this development we
have to give an answer we have to
prioritize this debate now we have to
prioritize it now and the epp always
insisting in jobs jobs jobs that is our
method and i ask you now to put this on
the agenda of the european council to
discuss this issue among leaders from my
political family i can tell you with
strengthening single market less
bureaucracy yes to trade agreements we
need the mercury agreement now and also
in this fit455 package of the day to
find a good balance we want to have a
decarbonization but not at the
industrialization of the european union
that is now on the table and that's why
we have to prioritize this issue
leadership is needed again thank you so
much
thank you
mr weber and now on behalf of the smd
group i invite iracia garcia perez
thank you ms garcia perez
now on behalf of the renew group i
invite malik asmani to take the floor
dear presidents
honorable members
while the war in ukraine carries on
our european unity becomes even more
important
it becomes more important
but also more
difficult even though the real suffering
occurs on our eastern border
we too feel the impact of war
the outcome of the european council
shows the european union can still
deliver
thank you for your leadership dear
charles
for securing the sixth package despite
the behavior of some
nevertheless we can and must do more
president
putin bets that our willingness to
increase costs on his regime will reduce
and let's prove him
wrong
let's show him we mean it when we say
freedom must overcome
tyranny let us prepare
for winter by increasing our energy
security and investing in a green
transition
let us continue and step up our military
aid so that ukraine has a chance to
determine the outcome of the battlefield
getting produced food out of ukraine
will stop putin using famine as a weapon
which could also lead to migration
crises here in europe
putin's cynical blockade of ukraine
sports shows his total disregard for the
global community
we must all speak out
our partners must also deliver
and we welcome egypt's refusal of russia
stolen ukraine wheat
dear presidents
we must be clear with our global
partners
as the u.s have been
that they must reject russia's plundered
commodities or face diplomatic
consequences
finally colleagues there can be no
impunity for war crimes
we knew europe welcomed the council's
conclusions supporting the isis fee and
the establishment of a joint
investigation team coordinated by our
adjust
and i repeat my call for more member
states to join legit to improve the
collection of evidence coordination is
the cure to duplication
duplication can be painful for victims
who have to relive their strategies to
investigators
and it will ensure the aggressors are
health to account
which must remain the ambition of this
house and its member states thank you
very much
thank you very much mr asmani next is
philip lambert on behalf of the green
group
scenario
[Music]
thank you mr lamberts and now on behalf
of the id group jack madison
thank you so much madam
president madame model mr michelle
first of all as i have only one minute
or one and a half minute i would like to
really agree with mr webber from epp
when he mentioned that actually we have
to discuss also about topics when we're
talking about inflation when we're
talking about the food security i really
loved when he mentioned that we
shouldn't see any more the farmers as a
huge risk or damage to environments we
have to see them as a producer for the
food and we know that we need a food
security to be more independent from
russia from china even from u.s
and uh of course like and if you don't
propose solutions if we can't solve the
real problems
for our citizens in european countries
then those bad guys that's called
populist will come with solutions
and of course
they propose sometimes very good
solutions if i call myself as a populist
sometimes
uh second thing about russia and ukraine
i think the sanction packet is of course
like a huge step forward but at the same
time we have to remind that from 24th of
february eu has paid over 50 billion
euros to russia for energy on the same
time we have proposed the military help
from the eu only for a few billion euros
and the sanctions are effective in the
long term maybe in six months in one
year but we have to think how to win
russia
in few months
in the end of the summer and we will
win the war if there is enough military
aid to ukraine and if german is not
doing enough as you see today by mr
schultz if france is totally
understandable not understandable if mr
macron is saying that we can't humiliate
vladimir putin
then it's your duty and it's your duty
to provide more military aid by eu to
ukraine to win this war and then we can
also look forward with the sanction
package to destroy their economy that's
the short term view how we have to react
and for the long term of course the
sanctions are necessary i don't agree
also with some member states who are
trying to block everything and are not
cooperating together
but
more thinking on the inflation economic
problem for our citizens and more
thinking about the military to ukraine
thanks a lot
thank you
very much mr madison next on behalf of
the ecr group rafael
a
next on behalf of the left group i
invite martin shared one to take the
floor
[Music]
foreign
diplomatic
um
then
when
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
is
um
[Music]
yo
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
dear presidents
dear colleagues
council made important decisions but
still there is a lot to be done in order
for us to come out from this
geopolitical crisis becoming stronger
in order to do that first of all we need
to look back and to name our mistakes
over the last decades
which allowed this geopolitical crisis
to happen
i see two major mistakes
first for too long we were considering
that dialogue with putin is more
important than democracy in russia
that is how we allowed kremlin to become
a new fascist regime and second for too
long we were keeping ukraine in a
geopolitical gray zone not giving it a
clear membership perspective and because
of that putin decided that ukraine is
his territory
we need to learn our lessons we need to
give ukraine kennedy status immediately
and also we cannot be effective during
the war with individual vital rights of
member states which simply creates
conditions for black male culture to
spread we add the war not just ukraine
and i would like to see that this war
will make all of us much stronger thanks
a
lot
abrigado
international america
well yesterday we had a discussion on a
polish recovery plan it was not a very
pleasant
discussion for you especially this time
i have the pleasure to
express my
appreciation of the results of the
of the summit
both for you and for you
this is this was important but not
obviously not the last time we are
discussing ukraine it's going to be a
evergreen for the next
weeks month
or maybe even more
one thing that i would like to
concentrate in my one minute
is the long-term reconstruction strategy
of ukraine
and i need well i would like to say we
need four things four major things
first we need a reliable partner on the
ukrainian side
which means we need a democratic
well-governed non-corrupt
well-managed
and
led with a strong hand i'm sorry to say
that this is not against democracy we
need a well-managed ukraine
on the other side
we need a leader of the international
community and this time it's obvious
it's going to be the european union
america can be a
very important
factor in military support of ukraine
but not in in the development in
reconstruction it's on us
and
we we have to well as a matter of fact
there is a thinking of uh creating a
europea ukrainian reconstruction
platform that would serve coordination
of international partners willing
to take part in the reconstruction of
this country
third we need resources
and the resources i mean public and
private
but uh i think that the european union
as a leader should provide
resources maybe also in a similar way as
we have provided it for the post-covet
reconstruction post-covet reaction
maybe we should follow the
experience of the rrf of the next
generation eu and
set up a fund a facility
to uh
to sort of
galvanize resources from other sources
and the fourth more most important what
we need for reconstruction of ukraine
it's political will it's the realization
that
coming return to business as usual with
russia is not imaginable
at the moment
and number
in the last point
we have to care for the victim more than
for the aggressor
[Applause]
sex intervention
um
the
madam president from the line mr
president uh michelle
we are very happy that the council
has agreed on another embargo uh
congratulations
but this agreement still has three or
comments as you said madame from the
line
there's still no mention of gas the
agreement excludes oil coming through
pipelines if you allow me the
urban putin pipeline is still open
and it will take six months to be
implemented in the meantime mr putin
continues receiving
inflated oil and gas revenue to pay for
his military aggression and mr orban
continues receiving his oil which comes
mostly through this pipeline
this is unacceptable we need
to stop uh mr putin reducing these
revenues and we need to shorten this war
and we also need to restore the level
playing field in the single market how
can we do that we can accomplish both
things by imposing a tariff on russian
oil imports uh madame from the line a 30
oil tariff would provide the european
union with around 15 billion euros in in
additional revenues and as i have
estimated elsewhere mr michel
russia would lose approximately twice as
much from the reduction of the oil
exports plus the direct cost of the
tariffs
a key advantage of the tariff is it
doesn't require unanimity so a qualified
majority of member states in the council
according to article 31 is enough to get
that tariff and recover the past and
recover the level playing field the
tariff could be enforced next week if
the council voted now let's do it now
this war has already lasted for too long
thank you thank you
thank you
thanks so much now we
go for the catch
uh catch the eye we have um requests for
from four different political groups so
i'll give one to each of those political
groups starting with sean kelly you've
got the floor
one minute
come on group john
president ursula was right when she said
putin's war of aggression is what fuels
the feud crisis
and of course on top of that there's the
wild destruction of the infrastructure
of ukraine a killing of its citizens and
raping of its women and while all this
is going on we have the president
of the rotating council macron talking
about we muslims humiliate putin
who's doing the humiliating why is he so
concerned what does that this actually
mean
he has to be asked these questions does
it mean
that ukraine is supposed to hand over
half his territory to putin so that he
can claim he wins the war otherwise he
is humiliated by losing the war
how would he like if somebody invaded
france and we started talking about we
mustn't humiliate the aggressor so part
of france should be handed over to the
aggressor
i think now is the time and particularly
at the next council meeting
to ask mr macron what does he mean by
this and why is he saying this now when
the lives of ukrainians are being
destroyed every single day come out ron
thank you next speaker
uh guilt bourgeois
uh as my colleague johan van overt
writes today in politico we have to be
prepared for the reconstruction of
ukraine
so this will
provoke a very very huge coast
vice president tom broski's argued for
the aggressor pace principle my question
is is there a decision on this
principle i agree with him is it
possible to use the confiscated money
around 600 billion dollar
and is there a legal fundament for it
thank you
thank you next speaker
you're the kanyes
president
if
abstentions
thank you
now we get to the final interventions
and i
give the floor to the president of the
european commission usually wonderland
you got it
thank you mr president indeed um
electricity prices energy prices are
skyrocketing and we are doing a lot on
it we have issued a toolbox that many of
our member states are using that is
taxing the windfall profits and
subsidizing thus the vulnerable
households and the vulnerable
businesses
but we also acknowledge that this is a
short-term relief that will not really
change something in the structure of the
market and what is the problem of the
structure of the market we still have an
electricity market
that is
designed in a way like it was necessary
20 years ago when we started to bring in
the renewables
so um it is the renewables that go in
first at that time much more expensive
and later on comes the other energy
energy topics like for example oil or
gas or nuclear or coal
and the one that comes last in the most
expensive is defining the price today
the market is completely different
it is the renewables that are the most
cost effective and the cheapest ones
and they come in and then at the very
end comes in gas gas is the most
expensive but it defines the whole price
and this market system does not work
anymore we have to reform it we have to
adapt it to the new realities of
dominant renewables this is the task
that the commission has taken over now
this is not trivial this is a huge
reform
it will take time it has to be well
thought through but
we need to step forward to adapt our
electricity market to the modern
conditions
my second point is um a reply to um the
question malik asmani put forward
we have done
steps in the right direction the first
one is we have now the common storage of
gas
and today we have 44 of our storages
filled this is better than last year
there we were at the same time at 40
percent so the common storage does
already work in the right direction
and we have formed just now
a a joint purchase platform so that the
27 member states
can together
jointly purchase for example gas
worldwide and this is so important
because we are a big market power if we
work at 27.
if we go everyone on its own it's
fragmented to 27 and there is not at all
a market power but if we work together
we should keep in mind that of the
pipeline gas we have
75
of the world's demand we hold it so
together we are strong we are powerful
and this we should use now and therefore
we have created this joint uh platform
for gas purchases
then um there were several questions on
relief and reconstruction
and yes
this is a big and mostly important topic
what is it first of all we need relief
for ukraine in the short term
as you might know um at the moment being
ukraine needs per month 5 billion euros
just to make it for the basics pensions
salaries basic services like healthcare
to upheld hold it they need five billion
and here we have to step up together
with others g7 already came forward with
a proposal
now we want to join the g7 and we're
working on the nine billion relief for
the next month from the european side
but the bigger topic
is indeed the topic
of reconstruction marek belka you
um mentioned a lot on that
reconstruction would mean
that the investment is colossal as
president zielinski said it is indeed
colossal we cannot do it on our own we
will carry our fair share but we need
others like the financial institutions
international and imf oecd g20 world
bank for example we need other partners
other countries to join and therefore we
will form a platform
co-led by
ukraine they have to own it and the
european union
to make sure that we have a common
direction of travel
and then the second thing that is so
important that these investments go hand
in hand with reforms
to improve the administrative capacity
of the country
to fight corruption to make sure that
there's an independent judiciary to make
sure that this isn't conducive
environment for the business sector
and we've done already a lot with
ukraine and we know already a lot about
each other we've done reforms together
the land reform for example to kick out
oligarchs for example so a lot has been
done through our association agreement
and the deep and comprehensive free
trade agreement we have a common grid
for example too
and therefore in the very end important
is the signal
there is no wild card for ukraine there
are no shortcuts the conditions have to
be met but if we invest and if we are
combining that with with reforms this
will pave the way towards the european
union and finally my last sentence yes
the perpetrator russia
has to pay its fair share so we are
looking into the legal basis to achieve
that thank you very much
thank you madam president now um
to close our debate uh i will give the
floor to president charles michel
president
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
security
[Music]
mercy
the debate is now uh closed and the
session will be suspended just for a
couple of minutes minutes so that we can
arrange things to receive the speaker of
the ukrainian parliament so the session
is suspended thank you
[Music]
you